wir werfen gleichzeitig einen Blick nach
Amerika wo in diesen Minuten
Jeff Bezos der reichste Mann der Welt
ins All starten wird
wir sehen den Countdown noch 19 Minuten
sind es bis dahin und wenn wir noch mal
einen Blick auf die Live-Bilder werfen
dann sehen wir dass Raumfahrzeug seiner
Firma blue Origin
startbereit new Shepherd ist der Name
und der Datum heute ist nicht ganz
zufällig gewählt es ist nämlich der 52
jahrestag der ersten Mondlandung das
sind also die Bilder aus der texanischen
Wüste die wir sehen die Besatzung ist
auch schon an Bord und ich möchte gerne
jemanden mit ins Boot holen zugeschaltet
aus dem Studio in Washington nämlich
meine Kollegin Nina Niebergall die wir
gleich sehen werden da ist Sie
Nina du warst letzte Woche mit dabei bei
Richard Bransons Flug in New Mexico da
warst du live vor Ort und hast das mit
begleitet dieses mal bist du im Studio
denn offenbar hat sich das Team Bezos
gegen die Presse entschieden es ist also
soweit wir wissen kein Journalist vor
Ort Nina die Frage die sich hier viele
stellen wir sind in Deutschland
erschüttert wegen dieser
Naturkatastrophe die wir hier erleben in
Amerika sieht man das auch
da fragen sich hier viele wenn wir so
große Probleme auf der Erde haben warum
müssen wir dann so viel Bohai um einen
Flug ins All machen stellen sich diese
Frage die Amerikaner auch
ja durchaus also einerseits finden viele
natürlich aufregend was da gerade
passiert mit Jeff Bezos fliegt der
gerade schon der zweite Milliardär
innerhalb von zwei Wochen ins All und
viele finden natürlich die Aussicht auch
aufregend dass bald ganz normale
Menschen Touristen und Touristen für
verhältnismäßig wenig Geld wir sprechen
da im Moment noch von circa 250.000
Dollar pro Ticket aber das eben ganz
normale Menschen vielleicht bald in den
Weltraum fliegen könnten das ist
einerseits andererseits ist es
tatsächlich auch hier so dass die
Menschen sehen ja es gibt die
Hochwasserkatastrophe in Deutschland
auch diese Bilder sehen wir hier es gibt
die Dürre und die Brände im Westen des
Landes und die corona-pandemie ist auch
noch nicht ganz überstanden und wie du
es gerade schon gesagt hast viele fragen
sich könnte das Geld nicht viel besser
in Klimaschutz investiert werden oder in
Unterstützung für die Menschen die hier
unter der corona-pandemie Leiden zum
Beispiel Nina während wir noch mal auf
die Bilder blicken sie uns aus der
texanischen Wüste erreichen vielleicht
können wir die einfach zeigen
konstant während wir beide weiterreden
Nina würde ich gerne eine Frage an dich
direkt weitergeben die Stefan ess über
Youtube stellt hallo Christina was will
besos im All Nina kannst du diese Frage
von Stefan s beantworten
jetzt weiß ich nicht genau ob mich Nina
noch hören kann ich sehe und höre wir
sehen das Bild aus Texas und da ist Nina
wieder ich wiederhole die Frage noch mal
also Stefan es fragt hallo Christina was
will besos im All
das ist eine sehr gute Frage
besseres möchte glaube ich mehrere Dinge
im All also zum einen sagt er dass er
einfach seine Perspektive verändern
möchte er möchte die Erde aus dem
Weltall anschauen und er möchte einfach
zurück zur Erde kommen und eine andere
Wertschätzung haben für unseren Planeten
das ist was was zum Beispiel auch
Richard Branson schon gesagt hat das ist
natürlich so ein bisschen die Vision an
der ganzen Sache das zweite ist aber
natürlich schon auch Geld und eine neue
eine neue Industrie ein neuer
Wirtschaftszweig man geht schon davon
aus dass dieser dieser space Tourismus
dieser Weltraumtourismus in einigen
Jahren viele Milliarden wert sein könnte
und es ist davon auszugehen dass Jeff
Bezos genauso wie Richard Branson und
auch tesla-chef Elon Musk da eben
mitmachen möchte
Nina mein Kollege unser Kollege
Christian Volk hatte zusammengefasst wie
viele Männer sich gerade an diesem
Wettlauf um das Universum beteiligen und
auch sich die Frage gestellt warum und
wir blicken ganz kurz auf diese
Zusammenfassung
das wiederum ist keine Zusammenfassung
des männlich dominierten Wettlaufs ins
All sondern das ist eine
Gesprächspartnerin die wir auch gerne
mit ins Boot holen an dieser Stelle
nämlich die Astrophysikerin Susanna
Randal schön dass Sie auch bei uns im
Studio sind und das mit begleiten sie
werden gerade zur Astronautin
ausgebildet und ihr großer Plan ihr
großes Ziel ist auch in den Weltraum zu
fliegen was empfinden Sie wenn Sie die
Bilder vom bevorstehenden Start in Texas
sehen
ich möchte auch in den Weltraum fliegen
allerdings möchte ich gerne zu
Internationalen Raumstation ISS ich bin
natürlich total gespannt auf dem Blue
Origin Start allerdings wird das ein
suborbitalflug werden also das heißt die
Raumfähre wird eben nicht in den
Erdorbit gelangen Sie die Astronauten
werden dann auch nicht zu
internationalen Raumstationen aufbrechen
sondern sie werden einfach nur mal kurz
hochgeschossen und fallen dann sozusagen
nach ungefähr 10 Minuten wieder auf die
Erde zurück also klar ich will natürlich
super gerne dabei wenn Jeff Bezos mir
angeboten hätte mitzufliegen hätte ich
definitiv nicht nein gesagt aber ich
möchte langfristig noch höher hinaus nun
ist er ja nicht alleine mit an Bord ist
auch eine Frau die wie sie als junges
Mädchen als junge Frau schon davon
geträumt hat mit an Bord zu sein nämlich
Wally Funk sie ist heute 82 Jahre und
musste so alt werden um sich diesen
Traum vom Weltraum zu erfüllen beneiden
sie sie ein bisschen
jein würde ich sagen also Qualifying hat
ja wahnsinnig viele Flugstunden hat was
fast 20.000 Flugstunden ist eine sehr
erfahrene Fluglehrerin Fliegerin und die
war auch bei den Mercury 13 dabei also
als sie noch jung war war sie wirklich
dabei hat es genauso trainiert ist
genauso ausgewählt worden wie die
männlichen Astronauten die er dann
letztendlich im Weltraum geflogen sind
mit der NASA und natürlich freue ich
mich unglaublich für sie dass sie jetzt
heute die Chance bekommen wird in den
Weltraum zu fliegen aber es hat auch
schon früher sein können ähm also ich
finde es wirklich schade dass sie so
lange warten musste vor allen Dingen
auch wegen der Diskriminierung die
damals eben noch gang und gäbe war wo
dann die Frauen die genauso gut
qualifiziert waren eben ausgeschlossen
wurden vom Astronauten Chor der NASA
ihr Leben ist beherrscht von der
Faszination für den Weltraum und ich bin
sicher sie fiebern auch jetzt mit und
sind sehr gespannt wie der Staat in
wenigen Minuten laufen wird vielleicht
können wir gerade noch mal gucken es
sind noch 15 Minuten wenn ich das
richtig sehe bis zum Start und
wir nutzen die Zeiten noch ein bisschen
um darüber zu sprechen wie die Kritik an
diesem Unternehmen auch ist Frau Randal
können Sie verstehen dass Leute zwar
Faszination für den Weltraum haben aber
trotzdem sagen Milliardäre sollten
lieber auf der Erde Gutes tun als sich
einen Wettlauf um das Universum zu
liefern
ja natürlich kann ich das verstehen und
ich verstehe auch die Kritik an vor
allem der astronautischen Raumfahrt es
wird ja immer wieder kritisiert haben
wir nicht genug Probleme auf der Erde
das sieht man jetzt gerade natürlich mit
der Flutkatastrophe in Deutschland sieht
man wieder dass der Klimawandel wirklich
das Thema der Menschheit gerade ist und
unsere Herausforderung aber ich denke
immer klar also wenn ich mich
entscheiden müsste sollen 100% der
Menschen 100% der Energie auf den
Klimawandel oder die Bekämpfung des
Klimawandels verwenden oder auf die
Raumfahrt würde ich sagen klar
Klimawandel hat Priorität aber wir sind
so viele Menschen auf der Erde wir
machen ja nicht nur eine Sache und da
finde ich es vollkommen gerechtfertigt
dass man auch sagt natürlich ist
Klimawandel eine große Bedrohung
natürlich müsste sich Leute dafür
einsetzen natürlich ist es auch gut wenn
sich gerade Superreiche Menschen dafür
einsetzen und das sollten Sie auch also
da bin ich auch definitiv dafür dass die
CO2-Ausstöße kompensiert werden und so
weiter dass sie an Umweltorganisationen
Spenden mit der löst vielleicht aber am
Ende macht uns gerade die Raumfahrt und
die Betrachtung des Weltraums macht uns
irgendwo auch zu Menschen und inspiriert
uns und ich denke jetzt auch gerade
Menschen die vielleicht mit den Folgen
des Klimawandels zu kämpfen haben
natürlich wäre es den lieber wenn es
diese Flutkatastrophe nicht gegeben
hätte zum Beispiel aber auf der anderen
Seite gibt es ja auch noch anderes im
Leben also sie werden jetzt auch nicht
nur ihr ganzes Leben damit verbringen
dieser Flutkatastrophe hinterherzutrauen
hoffe ich zumindest die möchten auch
Musik haben die möchten auch Literatur
haben die möchten vielleicht gute
Unterhaltung im Fernsehen sehen und die
möchten eben auch Raumfahrt sehen weil
dass die Menschheit voranbringt also ich
denke Raumfahrt ist eine Inspiration
gerade in dieser schwierigen Zeit
mit dazu der auch seinen ganz besonderen
Blick auf die Raumfahrt und auch seinen
Blick auf die Erde mit einbringen kann
das ist nämlich der Astronaut Thomas
Reiter hallo Herr Reiter grüße Sie sie
waren von 1992 bis 2007 ESA Astronaut
sie waren der achte deutsche im All sie
waren unter anderem auf der ISS und auch
in den USA damals zum Jetpiloten
ausgebildet auf der Shepherd Airport
base in Texas das ist aber wenn ich
richtig sehe zwar um die Ecke vom
Startpunkt wo wir heute hin blicken aber
nicht genau da oder Herr Reiter schön
dass Sie da sind was empfinden Sie wenn
Sie die Bilder aus Texas sehen
ja vielen Dank guten Tag an alle ja es
ist in der Tat jetzt nicht gerade um die
Ecke aber natürlich verfolge ich diese
Startvorbereitung jetzt mit großem
Interesse
es ist eine neuartige Entwicklung kann
man sagen dass
gewissermaßen kommerziell Menschen auch
in den Weltraum gebracht werden können
das war in der Vergangenheit eben nur
mit Hilfe von
Raumfahrtagenturen wieder NASA der
europäischen Raumfahrt Agentur
russischen Raumfahrt Agentur möglich und
aus europäischer Sicht kann ich sagen
aus Sicht der ESA der Europäischen
Raumfahrtagentur verfolgen wir diese
Entwicklung natürlich gerade was die
technischen Aspekte angeht mit großem
Interesse
Herr Reiter sie sehen auch das Bild aus
Texas können Sie uns erklären was da
jetzt in diesen Minuten passiert
ich konnte bis kurz vor der schalte
damit reinhören und das erste was mich
jetzt schon ein bisschen überrascht hat
ist dass diese Besatzung erst relativ
kurz vorm Start einsteigt wenn man also
in eine russische Sojus Rakete oder auch
in das Shuttle einsteigt dann geschieht
das etwas mehr als zwei Stunden vorm
Start da sind viele Checks dann auch von
der Crew durchzuführen und das zeigt
eben auch den Unterschied zwischen
diesen sagen wir mal mehr touristisch
geprägten Flug und dem was eben bei
Reisen dann zu einer Raumstation zu der
russischen Raumstation Mir früher bzw zu
der Internationalen Raumstation ISS
jetzt erforderlich ist also ich denke
mal die sind alle hoch angespannt freuen
sich natürlich riesig auf das Erlebnis
die volley Funk hat das vorhin in einem
Interview auch schon ganz toll zum
Ausdruck gebracht dass sie also
unheimlich gespannt ist auf diese
Beschleunigung und dann natürlich auf
den Blick aus 100 Kilometern Höhe auf
die Erde
an dieser Stelle kurzer Hinweis an die
Community wir freuen uns über euer
Interesse an diesem Event und wir würden
euch aber ganz herzlich bitten einfach
sinnvolle Fragen zu stellen und dumme
Kommentare einfach zu lassen vielleicht
gibt es ja was was euch interessiert was
jemand der mal im All war zu diesem
Thema heute zu berichten hat schreibt
eure wohlgemeinten Fragen und Kommentare
bitte in die Kommentare oder per E-Mail
an die eingeblendete E-Mail-Adresse und
ansonsten geht einfach weiter dann gibt
es für euch hier nichts zu sehen Herr
Reiter können Sie noch einmal sagen was
Jeff Bezos und seine Mitstreiter und die
Mitstreiterinnen jetzt an psychischen
und physischen Belastungen in den
nächsten Sekunden erwartet
ja also ich kann eben immer nur den
Vergleich zu den beiden Missionen machen
an denen ich selbst teilgenommen habe
man ist kurz vor dem Start natürlich
auch
gewissermaßen am Ende einer sehr sehr
langen Ausbildungsphase und kann es
eigentlich kaum fassen dass jetzt
tatsächlich nach mehr als zweijähriger
Ausbildung das endlich losgeht auch das
ist ja ein Unterschied zu der Situation
jetzt
für Jeff Bezos der dieses Programm ja
auch für lange Zeit vorbereitet hat ist
es sicherlich auch noch ein bisschen
Unterschied zu den anderen Teilnehmer
Teilnehmern zu der Teilnehmerin
also ich denke mal die sind freudig in
freudiger Erwartung dieser dieser
Ereignisses und dieses Staats dieser
Wahrnehmung der Beschleunigung und dann
in zu kurzer Zeit tatsächlich in Höhe
von 100 km zu kommen also da werden
wahrscheinlich Gedanken was könnte jetzt
alles passieren eher in den Hintergrund
treten sondern man fiebert diesen Moment
diesen wenigen Minuten die die Mission
ja nur dauert wirklich entgegen wenn wir
noch mal auf die Bilder schauen dann
sehen wir dass der Countdown losgelaufen
ist erzählt jetzt runter von
15 sind wir bei 14 Minuten das heißt
also eine knappe Viertelstunde haben wir
noch bis es losgeht und noch eine
Erklärung vielleicht Herr reitert zu der
Einblendung die da steht blue Origin ist
klar dass die Firma first human flight
bezieht sich natürlich nicht auf den
ersten bemannten Raumflug sondern auf
den ersten bemannten Flug dieser Firma
blue Origin denn das Raumfahrzeug selbst
den new Shepherd ist ja schon einige
Male unbemannt ins All gestartet oder in
die Höhe gestartet auch ab da darüber ab
wo das All beginnt habe ich gelernt gibt
es wissenschaftliche Definitionen und
wer denn von den beiden jetzt weiter
gekommen ist darüber können wir
vielleicht später auch noch mal sprechen
aber können sie auch noch mal erklären
was genau denn jetzt an dem an dem
Raumfahrzeug passiert und wie hoch das
Risiko ist für die die sich darum
kümmern ob das nun ein bemanntes oder
ein unbemanntes Raumfahrzeug ist
kurz vor dem Start
überwachen natürlich eine ganze Anzahl
von Ingenieurinnen und Ingenieuren alle
Parameter
der Trägerrakete die diese Kapsel dann
in Richtung von dem Weltraum bringen
soll die Betankung läuft im Prinzip bis
kurz vor dem Zünden der Haupttriebwerke
dieses diese Trägerrakete wird ja mit
flüssigem Wasserstoff mit flüssigem
Sauerstoff Betrieben der bei extrem
niedrigen Temperaturen in den Tanks dort
eingefüllt wird das heißt da verdunstet
eine ganze Menge deshalb wird da bis zum
letzten Moment solange es eben möglich
ist noch nachgefüllt dann werden im
letzten Moment die die Verbindung zu der
Rakete von den tankschläuchen getrennt
die drainageventile werden geschlossen
so dass sich in den Tanks etwas Druck
aufbaut ja und dann wird der der Start
im Prinzip von dem Boden aus initiiert
also es ist jetzt nicht so dass wie in
einem
Verkehrsflugzeug vorne im Cockpit eine
Krise sitzt und dann sagt so jetzt geben
wir Gas und los geht's sondern das läuft
alles
weitgehend automatisiert und von der
bodenkontrollstelle überwacht ab
ich würde gerne zwei Fragen an Frau
Randall weitergeben die sich nämlich
hier eine Community damit beschäftigen
was es bringt Armin Parser fragt über
Youtube glauben Sie dass die
Wissenschaft auch von solchen Flügen
profitiert oder haben diese Flüge gar
keinen wissenschaftlichen Mehrwert und
genau dieselbe Frage stellt Ansgar König
auch über Youtube bringt das wenigstens
ein bisschen was für die Wissenschaft
also meine Antwort dazu ist ja ich denke
schon dass es etwas für die Wissenschaft
bringen kann es ist so dass gerade bei
Blue Origin auch bei den unbemannten
Testflügen schon Experimente unter
anderem vom DLR an Bord waren die eben
Experiment in der Schwerelosigkeit
machen wollten die Raumkapsel wird ja
ungefähr drei bis vier Minuten
Schwerelosigkeit erfahren und das ist
sehr viel mehr als man jetzt bei einem
Parabelflug erfahren kann also ein
Parabelflug da werden eben die meisten
Experimente unter Schwerelosigkeit jetzt
nicht auf der Raumstation sein können
gemacht das heißt man hat schon sehr
viel länger Schwerelosigkeit als bei
einem herkömmlichen Parabelflug
sozusagen also das heißt ich denke die
Wissenschaft kann von solchen Flügen
definitiv profitieren und was noch mehr
davon profitieren kann ist auch die
Technologie denn ich denke es ist gut
wenn möglichst viele Unternehmen auch
gerne kommerziell
unterschiedliche Trägerraketen
unterschiedliche Systeme entwickeln und
es ist ja auch so dass blue Origin noch
weiter hinaus will die möchten ja nicht
bei den suborbitalen Flügen bleiben die
wollen ja auch am Landemodul für die
NASA Mondlandung zum Beispiel
mitarbeiten die möchten mit der new Glen
mit dieser schwerlastrakete Satelliten
in den Orbit befördern also das heißt
sie haben auch noch andere Pläne und das
ist jetzt erst der erste Schritt in
einer ganzen Reihe von Entwicklungen und
ein Flug von einer ganzen Reihe von
Flügen die geplant sind oder die auch
schon einer ist schon gestartet die
anderen wollen nachziehen jetzt
versuchen wir es noch mal mit dem
Überblick über den Wettlauf ins
Universum mit Christian Volk vielleicht
klappt es jetzt
rund 50 Jahre nach der Mondlandung von
Apollo 11 gibt es einen neuen Hype um
den Weltraum diesmal geht es weniger um
Forschung es geht vor allem auch um Geld
und neue Geschäftsmodelle für
Milliardäre wie Richard Branson und
Amazon Gründer Jeff Bezos beide wollen
so schnell wie möglich Geld mit
Weltraumtourismus verdienen Branson war
vor neun Tagen schon kurz im All basos
will heute fliegen doch es gibt
Unterschiede Branson hat bei seinem Flug
eine Höhe von 90 Kilometern erreicht
Bezos fliegt heute höher seine
Raumkapsel soll auf 106 km steigen zum
Vergleich die Internationale Raumstation
ISS fliegt auf 400 km Höhe die
Fluggeräte der beiden sind
wiederverwendbar aber auch hier gibt es
Unterschiede Branson startete mit einem
Raumflugzeug er benötigte zwei Piloten
bei basos dagegen funktioniert alles
automatisch ohne Piloten er startet vom
Boden aus und dann gibt es noch einen
dritten Milliardär im Rennen um den
Weltraumtourismus tesla-chef Elon Musk
sein Unternehmen SpaceX bringt seit etwa
einem Jahr NASA Astronauten zur ISS ab
September sollen auch Touristen mit
SpaceX fliegen und drei Tage lang auf
einer Höhe von 540 km um die Erde
kreisen doch es gibt auch Kritik an den
Plänen der Milliardäre immer wieder
behaupten sie den Weltraum für alle
zugänglich machen zu wollen aber
tickets kosten bei Richard Branson
derzeit mindestens
250.000 US-Dollar es ist also mehr prq
und weniger Weltraum für alle
damit ist auch damit ist auch die Frage
von djgg über Youtube beantwortet wie er
realistisch ist es dass so ein Flug ins
All in den nächsten 20 bis 30 Jahren
preislich für Normalos erschwinglich ist
ist das realistisch oder wird das noch
weit weg sein Frau reindal was glauben
Sie was Ihre Einschätzung
gut das kommt natürlich auf die Normalos
an also ich vergleiche das jetzt mal mit
einem Parabelflug den auch Normalos
sozusagen machen können ein Parabelflug
bei dem man die Schwerelosigkeit eben ja
am Stück 20 Sekunden erleben kann kostet
kommerziell ungefähr 6000 Euro und da
würde ich sagen das ist was das
natürlich für Normalos sehr sehr teuer
ist aber es ist dennoch etwas wenn es
wirklich der Lebenstraum ist dass dann
erschwinglich ist denke ich zumindest
jetzt in Westeuropa oder in Deutschland
und genauso sehe ich das auch in den
nächsten also nicht vielleicht fünf bis
zehn Jahren aber eher 20 bis 30 Jahren
mit diesen supporbital oder vielleicht
sogar Orbital Flügen die werden auf
jeden Fall günstiger werden das ist ganz
klar
inwieweit sich die Konkurrenz da
wirklich
gegenseitig anstacheln wird die Preise
runterzubringen das hängt natürlich auch
von der Nachfrage ab aber ich könnte mir
vorstellen dass man vielleicht in 20 30
Jahren für einige zehntausend Euro oder
so in den Weltraum fliegen könnte und
mit der Inflation könnte das dann
durchaus etwas sein was auch für
vielleicht die eine Mittelschicht als
einmal im Leben Traum auch erschwinglich
ist Herr Reiter eine Frage die die
Community jetzt sicher wieder aufregen
wird weil die sagen warum fragt man
diese diese Frage aber viele Stellen die
sich die Klimabilanz dieser Flüge wenn
das so kommt die Frau Randal das gesagt
hat und es tatsächlich immer mehr Leute
geben könnte die dann auch ins All
fliegen wie klimaschädlich sind solche
Flüge
ja das ist in der Taten ganz zentrales
Thema also die Frage nach der
Nachhaltigkeit
muss man sich natürlich stellen wir
wissen alle dass
Massentourismus auf unsere Umwelt sehr
negative Auswirkungen hat und wenn man
sich jetzt vorstellen würde dass mit
einer Frequenz wie heute
Verkehrsflugzeuge auf Großflughäfen
starten in gleicher frequenzitäten
starten würden dann würde das natürlich
unser Klima belasten
ich denke wir sind hier was die
Entwicklung der Antriebstechnologie
angeht ja noch nicht am Ende angelangt
immerhin kann man sagen dass gerade
dieses Trägersystem von dem Jeff Bezos
das flüssigen Wasserstoff und flüssigen
Sauerstoff verwendet also kein
Kohlendioxid in die Erdatmosphäre bläst
sondern da kommt bei der Verbrennung
Wasserdampf aus nichtsdestotrotz haben
sie natürlich Recht die Frage nach der
Nachhaltigkeit ist eine entscheidende
und die spielt auch heute natürlich vor
dem Hintergrund des immer häufig
werdenden Staats von Satelliten
entscheidende Rolle allein im letzten
Jahr sind mehr als 100 Trägerraketen
gestartet worden haben über 1200
Satelliten in Erdorbit gebracht und
nicht nur in der Atmosphäre hat es eine
Auswirkung sondern eben auch im
niedrigen Erdorbit weil dort immer mehr
raumfahrtrückstände rumfliegen also ganz
entscheidende Punkt ist tatsächlich die
Frage nach der Nachhaltigkeit
trotzdem unabhängig von all dem geht da
für viele Menschen in wenigen Minuten
ein Traum in Erfüllung wir sehen noch
mal auf die Uhr noch vier Minuten und 30
Sekunden ungefähr bis zum Start und wir
gucken uns noch mal an wer mitfliegt
also klar Jeff Base aus der reichste
Mann der Welt und der das
finanziert und schon seit Jahren
vorbereitet hat mit seinem Unternehmen
und wir sehen die gerade schon
angesprochene 82-Jährige us-pilotin
wall-funk und damit die älteste Person
die älteste Frau die jemals ins All
geflogen sein wird und wir sehen den
jüngsten Menschen der ins All geflogen
sein wird jetzt zwar gerade nicht aber
gleich sehen wir ihn vielleicht noch mal
den 18-Jährigen Niederländer Oliver
Damen Frau Randal noch mal ich habe die
Frage nach dem Neid gerade schon
gestellt ich stelle sie trotzdem noch
mal können Sie mitempfinden was diese
vier unabhängig von aller Kritik die
lassen wir jetzt mal außen vor
unabhängig davon jetzt in diesen Minuten
empfinden
ja ich kann es mir natürlich vorstellen
also ich denke die sind wahnsinnig
aufgeregt das ist natürlich etwas was
keiner von denen so schon erlebt hat und
die freuen sich einfach nur auf den Ritt
ihres Lebens hoffentlich und ja wir
drücken natürlich alle die Daumen dass
auch wirklich alles wie geplant gut
läuft und dann wir vier neue Astronauten
haben
Herr Reiter was die körperliche
Belastung angeht da könnte man jetzt
sagen mit 82
könnte schwierig werden aber was sagen
sie
ja gerade auch in Anbetracht der
Tatsache dass da so eine
ältere Dame mitfliegt die ja nun sehr
agilen Eindruck macht wie gesagt ich
hatte das bis kurz vor uns nach schalte
in dem Interview verfolgt zeigt das eben
dass diese Belastung in der Startphase
eigentlich von jedem der
einigermaßen gesund ist ertragen werden
können also die lastvielfachen die hier
auf den Körper wirken sind durchaus
vergleichbar mit denen die man
wahrnehmen kann wenn man beispielsweise
in der Achterbahn fährt zwar nicht über
so lange Zeit das ist sondern nur für
Bruchteile von Sekunden wenn so eine
Kabine in der Achterbahn unten
gewissermaßen durch den unteren Teil
geht und man mit dem
zweieinhalbfachen in den Sitz gepresst
wird hier
lastet die Beschleunigung für für wenige
Minuten auf den Körper aber das ist
normalerweise auszuhalten
dazu zwei Fragen an Sie Herr Reiter die
hier aus der Community kommen während
wir sehen noch knappe zwei Minuten wir
beeilen uns ein bisschen und sobald es
losgeht lieber Herr Reiter würde ich sie
auch bitten als Experten den Start zu
kommentieren aber bis dahin versuche ich
noch die zwei Fragen unterzubringen Rom
über Youtube mit welchem Schub wird die
Rakete eigentlich vom Boden abheben und
Eve Tolkien fragt wie hoch ist die
Startgeschwindigkeit
ja also ich muss sagen es ist über
dieses Triebwerk dass diese Rakete
antreibt relativ wenig zu erfahren es
erzeugt soweit ich das in Erfahrung
bringen konnte einen Schub von etwas
entsprechend 50 Tonnen und diese 50
Tonnen müssen natürlich also dieser
Schub muss natürlich höher sein als die
Gesamtmasse
dieser Rakete bei einer Sojus Rakete um
das einfach mal im Vergleich zu sagen
liegt die anfangsbeschleunigung also
unmittelbar beim Abheben bei ungefähr
anderthalb gehe das heißt der Schub ist
um das Anderthalbfache größer als das
Gewicht der Rakete die Beschleunigung
nimmt dann allerdings zu weil die Rakete
natürlich sehr schnell den Treibstoff
verbrennt leichter wird und deshalb
immer schneller beschleunigt also
unmittelbar beim Abheben werden wir
gleich sehen geht es erst ganz
gemächlich mit einem Lift nach oben aber
dann nimmt die Geschwindigkeit
progressiv zu und beginnen es sind jetzt
nur noch 30 Sekunden bis zum Start das
was sie gerade beschrieben haben das
werden wir dann also in Kürze sehen alle
Fragen der Userinnen und User die wir
hier noch haben die werden wir dann nach
der hoffentlich geglückten Landung
wieder beantworten und jetzt übergebe
ich sehr gerne an Sie Thomas Reiter
kommentiert
ja gut wir hören auch so ein bisschen
die Kommunikation durch die
Bodenkontrolle
so dann sieht das geht erst recht
behäbig los
[Musik]
die Beschleunigung dürfte also jetzt
stark ansteigen von den ungefähr
anderthalb g auf das Doppelte Dreifache
in wenigen Sekunden wird
mega Rakete dann ein erreicht bei dem
der maximale Staudruck auf diese Rakete
wirkt mit zunehmender Höhe nimmt ja die
Luftdichte ab der Druck nimmt ab und die
Geschwindigkeit nimmt zu also ist da
irgendwo ein Punkt erreicht der ist
meistens so nach knapp einer Minute
erreicht bei dem der maximale Staudruck
erreicht
[Musik]
das ist genau das was die Dame eben
erklärt hat
eben ist diese maximale staupunkt
bestätigt worden
und an dieser Stelle wird normalerweise
beispielsweise bei dem Shuttle der Schub
geringfügig reduziert und nach dem
Erreichen diesen Zustand wieder erfüllt
um eben die Struktur nicht so stark
Seite die Geschwindigkeit und die Höhe
also man kann erkennen dass hier nach
anderthalb Minuten Mann bereits fast
doppelt so hoch ist wie ein Airliner
85.000
Herr Reiter wie fühlt sich das an wenn
man da jetzt drin sitzt
ja man wird eben mit großen Kräften in
den Sitz gepresst und das was wir das
als weder in der sojuskapsel hatten noch
was Shuttle den konnte ist in der
wunderschönen Ausblick also hatten ja
wunderschöne Fenster hat jetzt sehen die
sich langsam der kommunizieren und die
die
blaue der Atmosphäre sollten Spaß
verändert
[Musik]
look at view sagt die Kommentatorin aus
dem uns zur Verfügung gestellten
Material von Blue Origin was empfindet
man in diesem Moment Angst oder ist das
Staunen darüber dass man nun endlich den
Blick von so weit oben auf die Erde hat
also die die Begeisterung die
Faszination dieses Anblicks überwiegt da
definitiv da ist kein Gedanke an Angst
oder an die Risiken die mit so einem
Flug verbunden sind dann ist einfach nur
begeistert Freizeit einigen Sekunden
herrscht Schwerelosigkeit also des
Triebwerk ist abgeschaltet und damit
fliegt jetzt diese Rakete und die Kapsel
im Prinzip im Freien ihnen im Freien
Wurf wenn ich also ein Stein nach oben
werfe genauso ist jetzt die Situation in
in dieser Kapsel und die fußfassung
man kann auf der linken Seite des
Bildschirms sehen wie die
Geschwindigkeit jetzt abnimmt eben weil
die
Schwerkraft eben jetzt die Daten
es ist insgesamt Herr Reiter ein kurzes
Vergnügen richtig insgesamt elf Minuten
sind für diesen Ausflug geplant
ja naja also das ist auch genau das was
ja das B so mit solchen Flügen
erzeugen und demonstrieren möchte dass
erstmal der Ausblick auf unseren
Planeten aus dieser Höhe das Gefühl der
Schwerelosigkeit für etwas längere Zeit
und man braucht sich ja also die
Besatzung hier braucht sich ja nun um um
nichts anderes zu kümmern sie brauchen
nicht die Bordsysteme dieses dieser
Kapsel zu überwachen oder sonst
irgendwas sondern die sind im Prinzip
dort Passagiere
Wohnmobil schreibt Wohnmobil 1998
schreibt über Youtube mir wäre das zu
gefährlich das Sehen wahrscheinlich
viele andere auch so viele Userinnen und
User fragen warum gibt es keine Kamera
vom Innenraum
ja das ist die Frage hätte ich auch das
wäre natürlich jetzt
eine tolle Möglichkeit auch noch mal
gewissermaßen aus den Augen der
vier Crew Mitglieder das erleben zu
können ich kann mir vorstellen dass das
zumindest aufgezeichnet wird wir sehen
übrigens jetzt hier auf der linken Seite
dass ich die Kapsel und die Trägerrakete
voneinander getrennt haben
und die
Höhe nimmt wieder ab also sie haben
jetzt die maximale Höhe bereits
überschritten dabei etwas über 300.000
man konnte das hören sie haben diese
sogenannte von Karmann Linie bei der der
Weltraum beginnt
das heißt die schwere eine eine geringe
Zeit Herr Schwerelosigkeit ist das eben
gar nicht genau
die die schöne Zeit der Schwerelosigkeit
ist schon bald wieder vorbei wie fühlt
es sich an schwerelos zu sein Herr
Reiter
eigentlich dein Körper gar nicht erst
was nicht das genügend geringste das
beste
mal ab
durch den Raum zu bewegen gut jetzt
haben die in dieser Kapsel nicht
besonders viel Platz wenn man an Bord
der internationalen Raumstation ankommt
die ja relativ groß ist als 76 Räder
lang
um von der einen Seite zur anderen Seite
zu schweben übt es sich bei ihm so mit
den Fingerkuppen abzustoßen dann schwebt
man schön durch die durch den das Innere
der Raumstation also Schwerelosigkeit
ist etwas was ein euphorisch macht und
jeder der beispielsweise mal
Parabelflug gemacht hat oder wenn man um
den Vergleich wieder zur Achterbahn zu
machen wenn man oben über diesen
höchsten Punkt kommt und dann so
nach unten geht das ist so ein kurzer
Zeitpunkt in dem Schwerelosigkeit
herrscht hier sehen wir jetzt übrigens
die Landung die Trägerrakete kommt
wieder zurück und setzt
erfolgreich auch so damit
also bei Blue Origin hören und sehen wir
sind sie erleichtert Herr Reiter dieser
Teil der Mission ist geglückt jetzt muss
nur noch die Kapsel sicher auf der Erde
landen was passiert jetzt
ja jetzt
dynamische Kräfte also die werden jetzt
wieder auf ihren Sitzen und hoffentlich
angeschnallt
reinschirme ausgestoßen
und dann sinkt die Kapsel schön milchig
Richtung erdbeerfläche zurück
ich nehme mal an das wird vergleichbar
sein mit der Sinkgeschwindigkeit mit dem
Fall der brustkapsel wo man wo sich hier
sieht was von die ersten
bremsfallschirme warum erstmal die
stabilisieren und dann werden in Kürze
die Haupt Fallschirme ausgestoßen
die Tatsache dass das
[Musik]
sichere Landung
was ist denn für die körperliche
Belastung anstrengender der der Start
oder die Landung was belastet mehr
statt was die Ebene
da etwas
unsere physiolog man allerdings verlangt
halt in der Schwerelosigkeit waren
halbes Jahr sich der Körper in der
Schwerelosigkeit an hat man dann in die
Erdatmosphäre
den Last vielfachen ausgesetzt ist dann
wieder am Boden ist
eben an die Schwerkraft geführt wird
dann die anpassen
die ein mindest so die erste halbe
Stunde Stunde
das ist nicht besonders angenehm jetzt
sind aber noch wenige Meter wenige
hundert Meter bis zur Landung ist das
jetzt ein kritischer Moment
nein ich meine da gibt es ja jetzt
nichts was man ändern kann die Kapsel
singt mit einer konstanten
Geschwindigkeit im Boden entgegen und
man wird sich dann sicherlich auf diesen
auf dieses aufsetzen vorbereiten so ein
bisschen die Muskeln anspannen und dann
hat ein Erde wieder
und jetzt ist es soweit
die Kapsel ist sicher gelandet und man
muss sagen es ist alles nach Plan
gelaufen wie funktioniert das überhaupt
wie landet dieses Trägerfahrzeug da wo
es hin soll und wie landet diese Kapsel
genau da wo man es vorher gesehen hat
können Sie das erklären
ja also die Trägerrakete nutzt natürlich
zum einen
Trägheitsnavigationssystem und
gewissermaßen Radar oder oder Funkwellen
um genau auf dieses landepad
zurückzukommen die Kapsel kommt einfach
am Fallschirm runter also da kann man
den Landepunkt jetzt nicht auf den Meter
genau bestimmen man weiß vorher wie die
Wände sind und kann bei der Flugbahn der
Rakete dafür entsprechend kompensieren
aber in dem Moment wo diese Kapsel fällt
die kann nicht steuern also die kommt
dann innerhalb eines gewissen
Radius ist um die statorme herum einfach
zum Boden wir konnten sehen kurz vor dem
Aufsetzen sind da so Staubwolken
aufgewirbelt da zünden in ganz geringer
Höhe so
größenordnungsmäßig ein Meter bevor die
Kapsel aufsetzt noch mal bremst
Triebwerke die diese sind
Geschwindigkeit noch etwas abdämpfen ja
und unten Rumpf und man ist wieder am
Boden jetzt sehen wir hier auf dem Bild
wir können jetzt durch das Fenster von
außen reingucken und sehen einen der ja
Astronauten darf man sie überhaupt
Astronauten nennen Herr Reiter ein
Crewmitglied was da relativ unbeweglich
noch in seinem Sitz verharrt was
passiert jetzt müssen die da so lange
drin sitzen bis der Rest vom Team kommt
und sie rausholt oder was was wird jetzt
gemacht
ja die warten jetzt darauf dass die
Rettungsmannschaften ja Rettung hört
sich jetzt etwas dramatisch an aber die
Ingenieure kommen dann Ihnen bei dem
Öffnen der Luke behilflich sind und ich
denke mal nachdem dieses Erlebnis ja
jetzt relativ kurze Zeit nur in Anspruch
genommen hat
nehme ich mal an dass man versucht das
jetzt noch mal ein bisschen zu
reflektieren
ansonsten gibt es da eigentlich jetzt im
Inneren nichts zu tun wie gesagt die
sind Passagiere sie haben keine
Möglichkeiten im Inneren irgendetwas an
dieser Kapsel zu steuern
und warten jetzt lediglich drauf bis die
Mannschaften von außen kommen und sie
dann wieder aus dieser Kapsel befreien
sie haben gesagt man braucht jetzt ein
bisschen Zeit um das zu verarbeiten das
Frau Randal da sind sie auch wieder mit
dabei jetzt ich weiß nicht ob die Damen
und Herren in der Kapsel Zeit hatten
selfies zu machen ob es überhaupt die
die Möglichkeit gab oder ob das das war
was sie machen wollten aber auf jeden
Fall sind das natürlich unvergessliche
Bilder und Frau Randall viele sagen auch
wir brauchen diese Bilder wir brauchen
mehr Leute die diese Bilder mit eigenen
Augen gesehen haben die von oben den
Blick auf die Weltkugel haben und sehen
es gibt nur diese eine Erde wir dürfen
sie nicht kaputt machen und das macht so
demütig dass die die das erlebt haben
wieder zurückkommen und sagen lasst uns
auf der Erde mehr tun um sie zu bewahren
ja ich weiß nicht ob der Blick auf die
Erde alleine reicht ich habe mir das
vorhin durch den Kopf gehen lassen
müssen habe ich gedacht okay man sieht
ja auch von dem Flugzeug aus wie
wunderschön die Erde ist wenn man jetzt
über Grünland fliegt oder irgendwelche
über Eisschollen oder so dann sieht man
ja auch wie wunderschön die Erde ist
deswegen denke ich schon dass der Blick
von oben gerade wenn man längere Zeit
oben ist wird der Herr Reiter zum
Beispiel oder auch die jetzige Besatzung
der ISS dass das auf jeden Fall schon im
Blick auf die Erde verändert aber ob
jetzt ein kurzer subopitalflug von vier
Minuten wirklich
ausschlaggebend für den Blick auf die
Erde für das gesamte rechtliche Leben
ist ich weiß es nicht also ich hoffe es
definitiv gerade wenn reiche Menschen
beteiligt sind dass sie dann natürlich
vermehrt in Klima und Umweltschutz
investieren aber das wird sich zeigen
glaube ich und wir sehen hier das nun
der Rest des Teams bei der Kapsel
angekommen ist und jetzt wahrscheinlich
gleich die Tür
äh eröffnet und dann werden wir die
Besatzung sehen wie sie rauskommt
Frau Randal sie haben auch alle
möglichen Trainings schon absolviert wie
ist man dazu Fuß wenn man jetzt aus so
einem Flug zurück kommt wackeln einem da
die Knie wie wie fühlt sich das an wenn
man plötzlich nach so einem Ausflug
wieder festen Boden unter den Füßen hat
vielleicht erst Frau Randall und dann
gerne auch Herr Reiter
und ich glaube das hängt wirklich von
den Einzelpersonen ab also ich sehe
jetzt diesen suborbitalflug das ist wie
eine Achterbahnfahrt es gibt ja so ein
Turm auch auf dem Münchner Oktoberfest
zum Beispiel wurden so hoch geschossen
wird und dann auch wieder runterfällt im
freien Fall und ich sehe das Ganze vom
Erlebnis her wie so eine turmfahrt der
Superlative natürlich und ich glaube
jetzt nach vier Minuten Schwerelosigkeit
dass ich Schwerelosigkeit habe ich auch
schnell erlebt bei Parabelflügen also
mir zumindest ging es danach wieder
sofort super also ich glaube die werden
auch ohne Probleme jetzt aussteigen
können und stehen können und sich auch
gut
ja ich hatte das eben schon kurz
angedeutet also nach so ein
überhaupt kein Problem
Sie dass ich dazwischen Grätsche aber
offensichtlich ist die bildleitung nach
USA besser als die tonleitung zu ihnen
weshalb ich gerne noch mal vielleicht
können wir das ein bisschen korrigieren
hier sehen wir Jeff Bezos samsap er ist
zufrieden deshalb gebe ich die Frage
noch mal weiter an Frau Randall bis Herr
Reiter auch von der Tonqualität her
wieder besser bei uns ist wie ist das
denn mit dem Sauerstoff eigentlich
mit dem Sauerstoff in der Kapsel genau
Sauerstoff in der Kapsel und jetzt
wieder bei der Rückkehr auf die Erde
genau das ist natürlich eine Druckkapsel
also die ist auch in dem Flugzeug ist
also die stand dann die ganze Zeit unter
Druck also die astronautenlosigkeit
erlebt haben aber die werden jetzt nicht
im warten gewesen sein also ich denke da
ja steht dann auch kein gewöhnungsbedarf
daran dass jetzt wieder auf der Erde
sind
und ein glücklicher Jeff Bezos dem viele
ja eine reine PR-Aktion vorgehalten
haben aber er selber sagt es geht auch
nicht um den Wettbewerb auch nicht um
die Mitstreiter zum Beispiel Richard
Branson oder Elon Musk das ist kein
Wettbewerb den wir Milliardäre und Ziel
liefern sondern es geht darum einen Weg
ins All zu errichten damit zukünftige
Generationen unglaubliche Dinge im
Weltraum tun können
Herr Reiter ist wieder bei uns habe ich
gehört was eröffnet dieser Ausflug ins
All zukünftigen Generationen aus ihrer
Sicht hat Jeff Bezos da mehr für sich
getan oder mehr für die Menschheit
also sie sprechen dann ganz
entscheidenden Punkt an in den
öffentlichen Diskussionen hat ja so ein
bisschen diese Aspekt des Tourismus im
Vordergrund gestanden der natürlich
seine Kehrseiten hat das ist ja alle wir
haben das Thema der Nachhaltigkeit
angesprochen aber lassen Sie mich laut
verzweipunkte
ansprechen die
übersichtlich eine ganz wichtige Rolle
also erstens mal kann ich Ihnen
versichern dass meine Kollegin Kollegen
genauso wie ich die schon mal
Gelegenheit hatten in Weltraum fliegt
sich wünschen würden dass er heute als
morgen das
glücklich sein Frage ist natürlich mit
welcher Technologie und da sondern
natürlich schauen ob diese Entwicklung
jetzt tatsächlich ein Anstoß gibt um
raumtransport
und das machen und auch ausreichend
umweltverträglich und dieser technische
Aspekt ist natürlich in diesem
Wettbewerb
der da besteht zwischen verschiedenen
Herstellern Basics mit allen Musk
Jeff Bezos an
ja Gesicht und denn wir wissen alle
Konsequenz belebtgeschäft und breit kann
man sagen dass Existenz verschiedene
auch natürlich Preis für Raketenstart
gedrückt
tja während wir also sehen wie hier die
Besatzung von Freunden Familien
Mitarbeitern begrüßt wird und sich
feiern lässt möchte ich gerne die Frage
nach dem Wettbewerb noch mal an Frau
Randall weitergeben Marco Reisen fragt
über Youtube wie ist denn die ESA für
die nächsten Jahre aufgestellt können
die noch mithalten Stichwort Konkurrenz
Frau Randal
gut also die ESA muss man ja sagen
Bilder natürlich Astronauten aus
Astronauten und astronautinnen aber die
Fliegen ja nicht mit den Trägerraketen
der ESA also die ESA Astronautin und
Astronauten fliegen eben ja entweder mit
der Sojus Rakete oder jetzt eben auch
wie Tomate den wir jetzt auf der
Internationalen Raumstation haben mit
der cool Dragon von SpaceX also in der
Hinsicht ist das keine Konkurrenz würde
ich sagen für die ESA es ist eher so
dass die NASA gesagt hat okay wir
möchten die Raumfahrt kommunizieren das
hat viele Vorteile es gibt kürzere
Dienstwege Sachen können oft schneller
entwickelt werden und die NASA lagert
das ganz bewusst aus um eben auch für
zukünftige NASA ESA jacksa also
japanische Astronauten den Weg
vielleicht zum Mond vielleicht auch
weiter zu ebnen und das ist ein ganz
ganz wesentlicher Aspekt denke ich der
Raumfahrt heute das eben die
kommerziellen Möglichkeiten voll
ausgelotet werden und die
technologischen Entwicklungen die
dadurch möglich sind also die NASA
begrüßt es auf jeden Fall zu Isa kann
ich jetzt kein Statement abgeben aber
ich denke dass es von den
Weltraumagenturen durch auch auch als
positiv bewertet wird
Abschlussfrage an Sie Herr Reiter von
Klaus Schwab über Facebook wir haben das
schon diskutiert aber es ist die Frage
die hinter allem steht den Traum
erfüllen sich nur die Superreichen was
haben wir davon
ja also das sehe ich etwas anders
natürlich gehört da eine Begeisterung
dazu und die Bereitschaft auch mit
Eigenmitteln entsprechendes Risiko
einzugehen
ich möchte in dem Zusammenhang noch mal
auf den vorherigen Punkt zurückkommen
die Position der ESA also zunächst mal
ist es nicht ein Interesse der
esa-raumfahrt Tourismus zu unterstützen
oder voranzubringen hier sehen das
ausschließlich unter dem Gesichtspunkt
des raumtransports das hatte ich eben
schon gesagt also
nach Wegen
möglichst günstig Raketen Satelliten in
den Weltraum zu bringen und damit eben
auch die Möglichkeit in Zukunft
vielleicht den Transportkosten für den
Transport soweit zu verringern dass das
eben auch vielleicht in einigen
Jahrzehnten mal für viele Menschen so
wie das vorhin schon gesagt wurde den
Normalbürger möglich ist dazu müssen
aber eben erst mal solche Entwicklungen
anstoßen und es ist ja durchaus so dass
wir auch in Europa und auch in
Deutschland Start-ups haben die neue
Trägersysteme entwickeln also die Frage
was bringt uns das jetzt in Europa oder
was bringt uns das so im tagtäglichen
leben muss man einfach sagen die Dienste
der Raumfahrt sind heute schon so stark
in unserem Alltag
vorhanden das ist viel Menschen gar
nicht bewusst wenn wir daran denken dass
wir heute die selbstverständlich mal
aufs Handy schauen um von A nach B zu
navigieren zu wissen wie lange brauchen
WIR um zu unser Ziel zu kommen
Wetternachrichten das was wir heute über
Klimawandel wissen wissen wir zum
größten Teil dank dieser enormen
Datensätze die solche
Erdbeobachtungssatelliten Aufnahmen und
vieles vieles mehr Telekommunikation ist
zu nennen und vieles mehr
Technologien die wir Zukunft benötigen
um eben beispielsweise die Energiewende
zu unterstützen um ökologischer zu
haushalten auch solche Technologien
werden teilweise durch die Raumfahrt
mitentwickelt und vorangebracht und vor
diesem Hintergrund muss man dann eben
auch diese Investition und diese
Entwicklung von solchen Entrepreneuren
sehen die natürlich hier ein
kommerzielles Interesse daran haben das
ist alles in Ordnung das mag
funktionieren das mag in wenigen Jahren
schon zu Ende sein weil das
Business-Modell nicht funktioniert aber
sie haben damit eine Entwicklung
angestoßen die hoffentlich die Raumfahrt
dann tatsächlich voranbringt und den
Nutzen für uns den tagtäglichen nutzen
dann erweitert
sagt Thomas Reiter vielen herzlichen
Dank dass Sie dieses Ereignis zu
begleitet haben mit uns und vielen Dank
auch noch mal an Susanna Randal für ihre
Expertise und ihre Eindrücke danke dass
Sie mit uns in der Sendung waren und wir
schauen noch einmal wie das ausgesehen
hat als vor wenigen Minuten der reichste
Mann der Welt ins All gestartet ist mit
seiner Rakete und sowohl dem jüngsten
als auch dem der
ältesten dem ältesten Menschen der Welt
die jemals im All gewesen sind und gehen
noch mal rüber zu Nina Niebergall
unserer Korrespondentin in Washington
die auch alles mit angesehen und
begleitet hat Nina wie ist denn die
Resonanz in Amerika auf diesen Flug
und jetzt natürlich parallel nur so ein
bisschen ins Netz schauen habe viel
Twitter auch im Auge behalten während
dieser Flug vonstatten ging und da war
eine Sache ganz interessant die mir
vorhin noch aufgefallen ist wir haben
jetzt viel über diesen Wettbewerb der
Milliardäre gesprochen und Blue Origin
die Firma selbst von von Jeff Bezos die
hat die ganze Zeit auch getwittert und
hat unter anderem getwittert das ist der
erste Weltraumflug sei ein der erste
private der über diese berühmte
kamanlinie drüber geht also der über die
Grenze geht wo quasi international
anerkannt ist dass man sich im Weltraum
befindet und das fand ich ganz spannend
vor dem Hintergrund dass der Jeff Bezos
immer immer bestreitet dass es hier um
einen Wettbewerb ginge aber das ist ganz
klar noch mal der Seitenhieb Richtung
Richard Branson der eben vor einer Woche
ins All geflogen ist und der diese Linie
knapp nicht überschritten hat ansonsten
sehen wir jetzt im Netz im Grunde das
was äh was vorher auch schon da war es
gibt viel Bewunderung dafür viel
Erleichterung natürlich auch dass alle
heil wieder auf der Erde gelandet sind
und es gibt aber auch nach wie vor die
Kritik dass hier viel Geld ausgegeben
wurde für diesen Flug ins All und das
ist eben vielleicht für dieses Geld auf
Erden auch eine bessere Verwendung gäbe
Nina weil du das gerade angesprochen
hast mit den mit den Kilometern wer da
jetzt weiter im All war als der andere
also es liegt nun mal nahe dass quasi
als ich nenne das jetzt mal mit ganz
derben Worten kosmonautischen
Schwanzvergleich zu bezeichnen da geht
es nicht um 15 cm sondern um 15
Kilometer in diesem Fall wir sehen also
tatsächlich es gibt diesen Wettbewerb
aber du hast es gesagt gleichzeitig wird
von vielen Amerikanerinnen und
Amerikanern auch wahrgenommen wie Herr
Reiter das gerade gesagt hat das kann
ein Fortschritt sein das kann uns auch
als Menschheit weiterbringen um hier auf
der Erde sinnvoller zu agieren und zu
handeln denn dieser Blick ins All und
die Gelder die damit auch in die
Entwicklung für Geräte und Technik
ausgegeben werden von denen wir hier auf
der Erde profitieren das lohnt sich am
Ende auch wenn wir diese Geschichte
erzählen können die wir gerade auch
erzählt haben
ja durchaus also es gibt eben einmal
diese diese langfristige Vision die Jeff
Bezos Elon Musk und auch Richard Branson
immer wieder ins Feld führen als
Argument es gibt aber auch die die
kurzfristige kurzfristige Argumentation
und die hört man auch von von
Erdbewohnern sage ich mal ähm die halt
sagen na ja das ganze ist eine neue
Industrie das schafft Arbeitsplätze auch
die Leute sozusagen die im Umkreis
dieser in Texas jetzt beispielsweise
arbeiten oder in der Nähe von dem
Spaceport America wo Richard Branson
vergangene Woche ins All gestartet ist
die sagen das wird uns hier Tourismus
bringen dass die Leute werden hierher
kommen und das wird wiederum
Arbeitsplätze schaffen
Nina lieber geil vielen herzlichen Dank
für diese
Begleitung unseres Streams nach
Washington und Ihnen liebe Userinnen und
User vielen Dank fürs zusehen da ist sie
noch mal da ist sie wieder weg und wir
sind jetzt auch weg tschüss machen sie
es gut